[Applaudissements]
c'est très très rare que ça arrive
il ya une jeune fille de moins de 50 ans
qui aime bien sûr qu'est ce qui se passe
car bella alors ilove jean-michel même
rattrapé la moitié ont pas songé une
femme jbt je suis majeur des majeurs non
parce que c'est juste pour savoir parce
que je ne veux pas avoir de problèmes
avec la justice bien sûr tout va bien
mais le film c'est jean michel mr ouai
mais pourquoi ça ne se commande avec
papy brossard ont quoi mais c'est
horrible mais pourquoi qu'est ce qui se
passe quoi c'est juste une couette c'est
pour que c'est de l'amitié auteurs de
l'étude parce que tu es jaloux de lui en
fait non qu'est ce que tu veux lui faire
un petit bisou
pourquoi pas ou sa bouche
la réponse oui veut
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
certaines visions
bien sûr alors ça pour ceux qui nous
regardent ne le fait pas chez vous ça va
s que tu puisses tu peux lui rendre son
dentier s'il te plaît